[Music]
last night on the show we did a sketch
about the new star trek film right
remember that i remember okay and at the
end of the sketch we ran fake star trek
credits fake credits well now the site
comicbook.com
is claiming that we may have spoiled a
major plot point of the new movie in our
credits and they really go on and on
about it well i have to respond just to
clarify those credits that we ran were
completely fake okay we were not trying
to spoil anything regardless of what
that website says we don't work that
hard no yeah no
yes yeah
but i'm surprised that uh that website
fixated on that particular sketch okay
because after all last night's episode
if you look at the whole episode was
packed with totally real star trek
spoilers really yeah if you look closely
at these clips from our show last night
see if you can catch any
tonight's episode in the new star trek
lieutenant buhura gets impregnated with
a klingon baby
what a great crowd we have tonight i
love that sign this woman held up a sign
that says conan we chose you over
studying for finals
how are you doing
let's take a look
spock is dead
please welcome ladies and gentlemen iron
and wine
[Music]
20 minutes in there's a pivotal scene
where the enterprise crashes
the
on
meets up with the star wars gang and
captain cook and princess leia bang
it's a surprising twist
nobody saw that coming
see
[Music]
yeah
now that i think about it i remember all
of those now